They bombed our house at the beginning of the war. We were displaced when we left the
house. We went to Al-Shifa. After a while, after the
Jews occupied Al-Shifa, we went to Al-Falah
School. We bombed the Jews, and in Al-Falah School, it
became a disaster there, and we were in
its heart. Then they threw
leaflets at us and told us to go to the
south. We came to the south. I went to Khons for a while
after that.
Khons were ashamed. After Khons were ashamed, we came to know. I
stayed in schools for a while, of course, the schools were empty
and rooms,
and there was only room. I
originally came here in the street and made a tent. I sat
next to my sister.
Of course, life is
difficult and the depression. Do you see that there is anyone
helping anyone? We
said we should make a small project for us like this to make a living
from.  And we eat, and our children
eat, and we live with this house project,
and here, thank God, our situation is somewhat better
than the first. I mean, we came with nothing because
we passed a long stage in the war while we were in Gaza,
and
even if we had money from the beginning, it was not lost.
Thank
God, the time is coming here because  Displaced people
and sitting people who want to earn a living. Living
like this is difficult. We are working as
sitting workers every day. Every day, we sell sitting
workers. The one who gives me wheat. The one who gives me a bag of flour. The one who
gives me and helps me to live. The children we
have and I am sitting in the tent. I mean, what can I do with the
situation like this? I have to.  She and I are you,
as you please see. I mean, we are working.
Praise be to God for our tiredness. Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds.
This is from the grace of God, and praise be to God from the satisfaction of
my mother. Praise be to God, Lord of
the worlds.